a long awaited football championship
gets underway in Iraq
the 25th edition of the golf cup is
being held in the southern city of Basra
The Opening match will see the host
nation go head to head with Oman to
attract football fans from across the
region authorities here have waived Visa
fees for fans
it's been a challenge for us because
we've been waiting for this Championship
to be held in our country for so long
there have been a lot of logistics and
Technical obstacles but we've finally
overcome them
Iraq first hosted the Arabian golf cup
in 1979 which it won but its invasion of
Kuwait in 1990 under then leaders Adam
Hussein saw it being banned from taking
part in international competitions
this Championship is significant for
both Iraq and the gulf countries the
government calls on all Iraqi fans to
show the best of their ethics and
generosity with our guests as this event
is very symbolic for all of us
two stadiums have been chosen for the
matches
the city's main stadium can accommodate
65 000 Spectators while the port Olympic
stadium has a capacity of 30 000.
the tournament is expected to have a big
impact on the city besides revenue from
live broadcasting of the matches
advertising and ticket sales many of
basra's roads and Facilities have been
upgraded ahead of the event which will
also highlight the city's tourist
attractions
fans from Gulf countries are here to
take part in the festivities
we've come by car all the way from Oman
to Basra to support our team the
tournament is reuniting all Gulf
countries
Iraqis take pride in their ability to
host a large tournament like this
they say it can prove crucial for their
suffering economy and renew ties with
the gulf countries and The Wider Arab
world
we Buster our residents are so proud of
this event it's the first in Iraq in my
generation we've been preparing for
months to make it comfortable for our
guests
basura has been affected by years of
unrest and conflict but if this
tournament is a success
it can be a destination once again for
more championships and golf Investments
in basura City Southern Iraq